if you're a fan of fashion then i am so
excited to introduce you
to our guests they're an influencer
couple who combine
fashion performance art photography as
well as talk about how you can dress
to express your love or
they are truly a viral sensation you
will recognize them from
every home page on your social media
platform
please welcome nelson and isabelle aka
the young emperor
i'm a huge fan and i'm so happy thank
you for giving us this opportunity to be
on the show
this is a dream thank you why did you
guys
start this whole thing and basically
start to match your clothes together
well it started when we got together and
we were in photography school together
and we fell in love
and sometimes by accident we would
notice that we would match a little bit
or be similar
and at that time i was really interested
in korean and japanese cultures
and they would match or twin
uh when they are a couple to showcase
their love to the world
and we thought that was just so us
in a way that really resonated so we
decided to do it too and
we became a duo professionally and in
life
and up to the close you know oh my god
and why did you decide to take this to
social media
well that was nothing mainly yeah i mean
we were doing matching outfit from the
start you know and uh
we thought uh it's better to do
something with it and also there was a
like um
a part of our work that we couldn't
explore as a fashion photographer and we
wanted to
explore it as a influencer yes i can say
so
yeah i mean we really see social media
like a medium it's a tool it's an art
medium just like any other art form
i mean mostly art forms like cinema or
even
photography weren't accepted as art
forms they were denied
and i think social media is exactly the
same why wouldn't it be an art form
you're right it is an art form and it is
the new opportunity and endeavor
and i just love what you put out into
the world the reason that i need your
instagram account is because it makes me
happy
it's beautiful and it really sparks joy
when i see it do you realize that you do
that for people
no at all no it's we're really doing it
for ourselves
we like spending time together yeah you
call it selfish
i say sometimes when you do things that
you think is for others like i do
everything for everyone else
but i don't try to think of what people
would
say about it you know and that way i can
be my truest self without any fear
and so sometimes being selfish and being
true to yourself
is the great way to share art without
being indulgent about it and being your
authentic self
thank you thank you for your
thanksgiving oh i heard you do a
zoolander face
yes all right let's kick it to
commercial all doing our best zoolanders
we've got
latigra blue steel magnum pick whichever
you want all right
ready and three two one we'll be right
[Music]
[Music]
back
you